hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es einen klassischen
saftigen nuss schoko gugelhupf das ist einfach
so klasse schlecker dem markt man immer und
ich verfeinere ihm später noch mit meiner
schokocreme das natürlich euch überlassen wird
euch aber alle genauen mengenangaben unten in
die infobox schreiben und auch sein alternativen
chocobos falls sie jetzt gerade zufällig nicht da
hab i startet direkt mit einer kurzen vorbereitung
dafür nehme ich mir die zeit bitter kuvertüre taxi
einmal fein und wird sie dann bei ca 600 watt in
der mikrowelle schmelzen und dann abkühlen lassen
für die kuvertüre ist geschmolzen die
haselnuss habe ich kurz angeröstet in
der pfanne und lasse ich auch noch mal abkönnen
das macht einfach viel leckeres aroma und jetzt
habe ich noch ein trick denn ich habe heute
auch vergessen meine mutter rechtzeitig aus
dem kühlschrank zu holen die habe ich jetzt
schon in stücke geschnitten und wird jetzt
ein trick anwenden damit sie schneller auf
zimmertemperatur kommt weil wenn sie kalt
ist dann lässt sie sich nicht so gut hören
dafür habe ich jetzt hier einfach nur große
schüssel gibt da heißt es wasser rein trocknen
sie aus und gibt sie dann kopfüber wieder drauf
und jetzt je nachdem wie kalt es fünf bis zehn
minuten warten und dadurch wird sie halt weich
und wir können direkt gleich die küchenmaschine
nehmen und ihr dürft übrigens natürlich auch
hier in dem rezeptor handrührgerät benutzen
falls sie keinen küchenmaschine habt so ich
starte jetzt mit dem talk alles wirklich
ein sehr schnelles rezept ich gebe jetzt
die weich gewordene butter einmal in
die küchenmaschine da kommt zucker mit
dazu und dann wird das drei minuten nach vor
geschwindigkeit gerührt und danach gebe ich
die zimmer waren eier mit dazu und rühren
jedes einzelnen so circa 20 sekunden ein
so jetzt habe ich auch schon die tat bitter
kuvertüre rhein gegeben da auch darauf achten dass
sie wirklich nur noch handwarm ist und allgemein
darauf achten dass die zutaten zimmertemperatur
haben denn eier und butter die verbinden sich
nicht ganz so gut aber so habt ihr halt keine
großen stückchen oder probleme dass die halb
zwei komplett unterschiedliche temperaturen
haben und als nächstes völlig alle trockenen
zutaten nicht mehr mail gemeine haselnüsse
bakker kann es einfach noch ein bisschen
intensiver wird backpulver und gehackte
haselnüsse die förderlich erst mal in einer großen
schüssel und geht sie dann mit zur mit zum teil
der teig ist auch schon fertig ging echt schnell
so sieht er aus von der konsistenz und ich werde
ihnen jetzt auch direkt einfüllen ich nehme
mir gesagt heute einen guglhupf form und werde
sie jetzt erstmal mit butter ausstreichen
und dann bemühen ich nehme aber mail mit
back damit dann später am äußeren rand meines
google books ist nicht alles so wie es aussieht
jetzt würde ich den teig ein und streiche an
der oberfläche alles schön glatt und dann kommt
in den vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad
ober und unterhitze für 48 bis 50 minuten
macht auf jeden fall gern die stäbchen probe
und das geniale an diesem kuchen ist dass er
sich wirklich fünf tage lang hält und die
bleibt immer saftig der ist einfach genial
jetzt habe ich den google ruft noch mal
vollständig auskühlen lassen denn dann
bekommt ihn ganz einfach aus der
form einfach stürzen nimmt dafür
zum beispiel so ein up kühl gitter oder
auch teller das auch kein problem umdrehen
ich gebe mein google hofft jetzt auf eine
schöne tortenplatte wundert euch nicht dass
der sehr dunkel aussieht das liegt am bug
cacau job in der kamera wirkt auch noch
mal ein ton dunkler da dürft euch nicht daran
stören oder falls sie nicht nackig lasst dann
könnt ihr natürlich auch euro vor mit paniermehl
ausstreuen wenn wir es nicht so dunkel ich mach
jetzt noch den besten kuss der welt oben drüber
und zwar nehme ich meine schokocreme das ist ja
auch eine haselnuss krämer aus der perfekt zum
kuchen einfach bei 600 watt für 45 sekunden in
die mikrowelle geben alternativ einfach im
wasserbad und bisschen erwärmen dann wird
ziemlich richtig schön flüssig und jetzt den
kompletten kuchen damit noch einstreichen ich
bin da eventuell gleichen pinsel aber ich gucke
einfach mal wie es optisch am schönsten aussieht
jetzt kommt der berühmte test
test ich habe übrigens zur deko
nur noch haselnuss krokant und das kam
so verwirrt mich als in dir kommen wir
probieren richtig heftig lecker aus
also alle die haare fallen ihr haben
schaut weg wir probieren von einem stück
europa teil ist romantik ist so hallo
wach weil dadurch der knallt 1000 colada ist
richtig schokolade und das ist lustig lustig
schokoladig tun hast du diese hasen bis zu lieben
so nusskuchen mit lokal mega also richtig geile
kombi war es könnte auch so ein riegel sein
dass ein frieden mega wohl stärker dazu so
einen leckeren latte setzte diese proteine regeln
ist ein bisschen ein bisschen frau constanze ich
weiß aber dass sie wollen gerne gesungen aber sie
schaffen ja stimmt ja genau und lecker schokocreme
euro ja es hat doch sehr oft sind videos dass
das eine kurve süßen aber diese wirklich ist
die sind diese papiere aber gerade richtig süß
leute macht die nach komm zurück zum video und
schreibt mal feedback unten in den kommentaren
und ansonsten nicht ich kann mir den genießer ich
gönne mir den es neben kaffee und haben so haut
sein stück ziehen noch weg und dann vernichten
wir euch die spaß und nachmachen manchmal kann es
einbricht so einfach so in die mitte und hessen